so there's another question that's
coming uh from
uh someone named scarlace
and scarleigh's here she says i love her
videos i have a question for her she has
repeatedly bashed theories like string
theory for being scientifically lacking
in their predictive power or provability
yet she believes in super determinism
how does she rationalize this position
well because super determinism does make
predictions
i mean like
i've given talks about this i've written
papers about it um the problem is that
the the experiments are not being done
so i'm trying to get people
um to actually do these experiments
um
i've i'm actually i'm always surprised
that people think i'm bashing string
theory or that i'm highly skeptical
or something i actually think that
string theory
does have quite some merit you know it's
it's based on on on a good idea um and
it was trying to solve an actual problem
which is the missing quantization of
gravity
i think he kind of
went into the wrong direction
um
when when they were trying to
hard to make things work out and so on
and so forth so maybe if they had been a
little more intellectually honest early
on then it wouldn't have gone downhill
quite as far but i mean there's some
interesting things that have come out of
it and the adcst stuff um is certainly
worthwhile um so that that's all fine
with me
this is uh ciznad oh
sitos asked what do you think about the
free will theorem
uh and uh have you seen john conway's
lectures on it his philosophical
arguments i think if you look at it the
right way
free will theorem and super determinism
will turn out to be equivalent now i
always say sabine i believe
in free will
because i have no other choice
but uh what do you make about this uh
free will obviously it plays and i think
the main answer is by the book because
she she covers that in great detail and
she has some videos on it
buy it listen to it in all three formats
um so maybe we'll move on to
other questions
um
here's a question the nothing channel
sabina is critical of the particle
physics field but is also against
building larger colliders i understand
her points but then how does she think
we go forward should we just give up on
particle physics until we get more clues
to guide us and how will we get those
clues thank you nothing channel
it's not that i'm against particle
physics or something like this i i've
been
very specifically against building this
super expensive a future circular
collider
because i just think it's too much money
for too little benefit
now there are certainly interesting
things that you can still do in particle
physics uh it's not that i'm saying
let's let's throw out or particular
physicist um i'm not quite that uh bad
but also i mean i've i've extensively
talked about what we should do instead
uh right i've i've literally written a
whole book about it um i'm i'm saying we
should focus on trying to resolve actual
inconsistencies for example the missing
quantization of gravity is one of them
and there's the measurement problem
there's also dark matter um which um he
just said
you'll be talking about uh with with uh
someone in the channel in the near
future
um so which of course we're already
doing experiments about like for example
the web telescope right it is giving us
uh better data as we speak
and that's certainly something that we
will learn from it about about dark
matter so it's not like we're completely
stuck without building this huge climate